my movie I spend a lot of time alone as
a kid I was a loner and I spent a lot of
time kind of in my room because I just
just felt comfortable that way and when
I was alone I would just draw pictures
and I would write little stories and I
would make up little characters and you
know what I was doing was I was
exploring a world that maybe perhaps I
could fit into because I wasn't fitting
in very well to the world that I was you
know that I was living in at the time I
had a very happy childhood and I had
great parents and three great sisters
but um you know sometimes that's
creatively where you need to go to start
dreaming and to start writing down your
dreams and then which is a lot easier
today than it was when I was a kid you
can actually get your your device your
phone and tell a story with it pretty
like it hurts